new girlfriend right I'm careful with
the term but yes okay the new girl
you're dating you've got yourself a
first class ticket and you put her in
economy
he has a human that I am putting you in
a three thousand dollars when you do
that stuff in the beginning
setting a poor precedent you are a
cheapskate though
what's your thoughts did he do it right
like he knows the girl for two weeks and
he refused to pay her the first class
tickets and he just let her sit in the
economy but he treated himself
I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't get on a
flight with any gal within the first two
weeks or let alone pay for her flight
within a two weeks so that seems strange
from from gecko interesting you know he
he like he decided that he barely knows
her for two weeks and that he she
doesn't deserve to be taken enough uh
first uh on the first ticket flight uh
where was he flying her to that's just
the short clips I don't have the full
context so somewhere in America you know
from Cali too you know but to LAX I
think but you know it seems like a date
no I don't know business meeting
anything it doesn't really matter but he
well I think it's interesting like how
he decided that she doesn't deserve to
sit in the first class because she just
knows important how about how about she
doesn't deserve a flight period like why
would you fly a chick after only knowing
her for two weeks I mean you got to be
pretty thirsty to do something like that
like I get the notion as well she
doesn't deserve first class the way that
I fly so I'll put her in economy because
I don't really know her that well but
why even fly her anywhere like why not
just not do it well you know let's say
that you want to take her why not you
know you can meet her while already
doing something useful so why why don't
you have other options like I would have
better options than to have to fly some
chick that I barely knew for two weeks
somewhere it just doesn't make any sense
the way that I so the way that I think
is why would I invest into a chick that
I've only known for two weeks at that
level like even if she was a 10 who
cares you got to have somebody else out
there that you're talking to that's at
least nearly as attractive
um it seems like beta Behavior to me you
know if I'm being honest but the fact
that he goes and puts through an economy
and he takes First Class People gonna be
like yo King you know like Well Done
sort of thing I get it and that's why
that probably went viral and you came
across it but I just I mean I wouldn't
even fly her anywhere in the first two
weeks like I don't even know you chick
yeah but you know it's interesting like
his friends called him like cheap and
Cheap's cake and like uh whatever people
you know what people will call you cheap
and Cheapskate to try to motivate you in
a certain direction because Society is
is telling guys do the right thing right
they always tell women you do what's
right for you girl look uh I've been
called cheap you know by checks before
I've been called cheap by friends before
um but just because I don't want to do
what you want me to do you can call me
whatever the [__] you want to call me
I'm not doing what you want me to do
right so that's the only reason why
people try to shame you in that yeah
yeah yeah that's like funny how like you
know he decided like oh it's a funny
clip I mean there's no question about it
yeah it's funny but but I still question
like why are you simping for this chick
like don't you have other options like
if you're going to another city don't
you have a check in that City if you're
so well traveled you see what I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah maybe that's just me you
know it's fun it's funny like finally
definitely like you know you know I
don't think there's a lot of dudes that
would like have the balls to buy
themselves the first class ticket but to
put their chick like in economy like
that's that's you know like some then
those area uh approach I mean look man I
I you know I flew to Sardinia this
summer with my gal and I flew business
uh you know across the pond and she sat
right beside me and I paid for it so
like if you've got your [__] together
and a girl's invested into your
relationship and she's done things for
you and she's been there when you're
sick and she's like you know she's that
type of material yeah yeah she's fine
but two weeks in I wouldn't fly a chick
anywhere man it just it just seems
stupid to me I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out